valentine's day you know what that means
I will tell you what that means that
means if you have a girlfriend
odds are you're going to see this exact
movie this weekend don't know what to
say just you embrace it and you accept
it as fact luckily I'm here to tell you
what you're in for at that point so
let's review it
[Music]
about last night - about last night's a
romantic comedy on Valentine's Day
because the universe demands that that
happens and I guess this movie's a
remake of an 80s movie I had no idea
about that until about five minutes ago
so I'm not even gonna touch on it let's
move on it stars Michael Ealy he's this
really nice guys an upstanding
individual he's - do you want to root
for because he's the common man and es
his friend Kevin Hart Kevin Hart is this
Lisa he's an [ __ ] so what is in the
movie he's is really loud obnoxious
[ __ ] but he does the role so well
Kevin Hart starts dating this girl and
then that girl has a roommate who starts
dating Michael Ealy so they're both
friends and they're dating each other
and it's a square's what it is it's a
square of personalities that all work
well together I really mean that
among the cliche plot of people are
dating people and you know how the story
arcs are gonna go I'm telling you there
are no surprises in this movie I say
that a lot movies the part of me that
thinks maybe it's because I watch a lot
of movies but I'm just saying in
romantic comedies there's a formula
there's a structure this movie holds to
that structure so at that point you're
like well are the people any good and
the people in it are good they worked
well together they have good chemistry
for nothing else you enjoy watching them
they say what you want about Kevin Hart
point is he has a huge personality and
it shows in this movie you stick him in
any room you stick him in this stadium
and you're gonna know he's there you
really that's Kevin Hart right over
there what he would rage out on things
I'm just looking at him I'm like hey
[ __ ] it okay the dude he cracked me up
in the movie good job Kevin Hart we will
now forget about right along cuz Kevin
Hart's that guy yeah the guy's like
screw relationships screw them I'm
happier and you watch the movie and when
mr. upstanding citizen Brigade is having
relationship problems you're like [ __ ]
what a drag you look at Kevin Hart and
you're like you can't argue he's happier
than the other guy so maybe that is the
way to be in life maybe that's the
message of the movie however like I said
good chemistry aside you watch the movie
and you're like I know how this is gonna
go down because it's that I know how
it's gonna go down as a romantic comedy
on Valentine's Day how else would this
go down and in that when they're holding
to the structure that it has to do some
things seem really abrupt you're like oh
everyone's happy all this [ __ ] they're
fighting they're pissing why are they so
pissed at each other my god they're
really mad why how did that happen and
you realize
this movie takes place in the course of
about a year and some people are pissed
at each other and then the next scene
it's a really really monumental thing
you're like what how long have you two
been mad at each other probably a month
seems like everything went from heaven
to hell in one day but it's just been
building over time for them just doesn't
feel that way for you and among that
choppiness throughout the movie even at
the very end of the movie I was like
okay it's wrapping oh those were in
credits
all right let's beat traffic let's go
movies Howard youyou leave now so about
last night it's a good romantic comedy
date night movie it has a cliched
premise for sure but it has good
characters that work well with each
other the actors did a good job relating
to each other I will say about last
night is a good time no alcohol required
I thought I was gonna vomit all over
this movie like a Matthew McConaughey
romantic comedy in the 2000s yeah I
guess not right so about last night have
you seen it what did you think about it
more importantly what is your ideal
Valentine's Day movie whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you
[Music]